well I knew I wasn't going to college
because I barely got out of high school
I said better find something right quick
so what am I good at you know as I was
making people laugh I'm busy I'm really
busy so I gotta tell people like the
president of nice days Mandela I can't
hang out with them because I got to go
look first time I met him in Willie
Morris office and you just keep talking
I said look at this guy's why why he
keep talking announcing a jump off a
20-story building with no pad for the
hall I said slow down the challenge
dude he's an American actor and stand-up
comedian he's best known for his roles
as smokey in the film Friday and
detective James Carter in the rush hour
Theory he also became a frequent
standard performer on def Comedy Jam in
the nineteen nineties Chris Tucker and
here's my take on his top 10 rules of
success rule number three is my personal
favorite and I'm true the true grit
which one you guys like the best and as
always guys as Chris is talkin if he
says something that really resonates
with you please leave it in comments
below
for quotes around it so other people can
be inspired as well enjoy
[Music]
when did you know that you wanted to be
a comedian look we really younger a
little older when I was young I was in
high school and I knew I wasn't going to
college because I barely got out of high
school what's that better find something
right quick laughter what am I good at
you know as I was making people laugh
and I was like wow y'all laughing are
you funny you remind me Eddie Murphy so
I said let me try this out now host my
talent show in high school and I got my
first laugh and I got an epiphany and I
was like I'm gonna do this no cuz it's
fun and I'm already you know so that's
when I found out I hosted my first
talent show hosted of talent show in
high school and that's what I want to do
what advice would you give people based
on your own experience about how to
manage the money oh man you know what
you know it's been vesting yourself
that's the number one thing don't go
invest and stuff you don't know about
such a nine times out of ten you
probably going to lose it or you're
gonna get scammed out of it cuz whoever
you invest away they know more about it
than you and they go they go say well
let me just take this if you don't know
what he's doing so investing yourself
you know and try to own as much as you
can and save you know save your money
but I saving its investing in yourself
if whatever it's equipment or keeping
yourself healthy or whatever because you
know the longer you stay in whatever
business you in the more likely you're
going to you don't keep making money
you're going to keep being relevant I
look I look towards the future and the
future is just you know it's more to do
is is more more steps to climb and stuff
so I don't really look at you know what
I'm doing right now I'm just every time
I do something I move on and see how
could I get better and I'm never
satisfied you know I think I always know
I could do better you know oh you could
be better I feel better yeah so all that
stuff I was just dreaming about like
this is the possibilities that can
happen if I moved to California or you
know so I was working really hard here
and a lot of comedians come down from LA
and sigmay you need to go to California
so she's pretty good I was getting a lot
of good advice
a lot of people who was really rooting
for me yeah when they did it but I had a
dream and that dream mom gave me no
confidence to keep going the power of
believing and dreaming is real because
that's all I did was dream and believe
and that these things could happen and
it made me feel good and that was my
that's true well if you believe and
you're doing something you have a goal
you have a dream to get somewhere it
makes you feel good I'm hoping it jumps
on me a 20-story building no Paxos all
I've had to slow down
new surprising every day was something
different and you was like it was real
fun I'm glad he did it that way because
you know you had to get up in the
morning you know you don't know what
they expect and it was a it was a real
good experience and my part was a
stretch for me because I never did
anything like that before and it was so
far from me and what I do in America
stand-up comedy you know I do like
reality jokes and stuff and my movies
that I used to do a reality like base of
America situation stuff it was nothing
like that but when I got there and John
Paul quartier I've seen all his clothes
do you want to mean where I go there's
not gonna be nothing like I have number
four boy if you like why I would never
wear to stuff in the street so far
nothing ladies to the boys house and hot
so I was like Shh just going hard and
John Paul could be the business
beautiful knew you would like this
I was like no I do is not collected but
I start wearing stuff and I start
getting into the carrot and it helped
the Cosmo help me create that character
a lot so zombies I'm real big so I gotta
tell people like president nice days
Mandela I can't hang out with them
because I got to go Luke
oh hell are you coming well I'm in
session always didn't make it better
it's okay I'm on for section
okay surface enough I am a post section
55 is when Bob Chris really shot Bobby
one highlight question because they
bring the best out of me you got it
let's go i watch everything down to the
last detail because I mean trust them I
don't know how they're gonna edit me I
gotta go people myself this will mark
the editors which lets out we together
they make it look good makes it fun not
funny tonight you know I've left up stop
begging in keep it going my fans and
everybody they don't want to see the bed
I look out number one I have a good
partner who started out as my manager
network partners and and I say that to
him because I say you know I learned a
little bit over the three years that
that I didn't do movies I learned a lot
more about business about the business
how I work and about movies and
everything so I think it's appropriate
to say we're partners because he does
some of the business side and I do the
you know exercising its Tracy Cramer
nice but that's definitely far as a
business you know I think he sees the
same vision that I have and where I want
to go and talk about that vision it's a
vision of doing something different and
not doing doing what's already been done
because I always think you know you know
I'm trying to evolve as a person and
also as an actor in two great movies I
think it's a lot of good stories that
haven't been told yet I think it's a lot
of uh and you know a movie should be and
Harry Belafonte told me this and I never
forget it he told me movies should be
how life is
I mean how life should be not how life
is you know so and I always remember
that because you know you know life
should be perfect it should be good but
it's not and so yes is that shoes I
can't believe it I kind of believe is
this happened to be in a movie who it is
and what should we want to call so maybe
women hello hey Tracy I just when is
talking about Jim Owens Valley Road okay
hold on Charlie Rose what's up Tracy
this is Charlie Rose and I just asked
him who was responsible for success we
didn't know you were calling here
obviously where are you in Los Angeles
didn't you know he is doing taping this
show
you did and you know what to expect on
this show you think Chris can handle it
now let me just ask you this
he comes here to do the show and so I
said to him we talked about this
remarkable success and I said to him is
anybody else responsible for your
success and he said not one single soul
he said I got this manager who I made a
partner and I'm not sure that was a good
idea who I haven't like God after
conceiving the dreams to become a
stand-up comedian and actor Chris began
the blind necessary to realize them
including working at his only job
outside of the entertainment industry
his father's janitorial service you know
I used to work that at night early you
know eight to like eleven then I would
go clean up McDonald's Burger King as
Chris poop Crystal's at that time
because I had the freedom took my dad
had his own business and he taught me a
lot of talking how to be a businessman
he taught me how to uh you know work
hard hard work and I put that into my
stand-up career in my acting career
you know the lesson I've learned just
you know always you know make friends
you know make friends and and
communicate just don't isolate yourself
because you know in this business is ups
and it's downs but the people you know
are people who really know you till they
know who you are somebody say something
bad about your lying like that I know I
really know him so we have you know like
in any other thing in any other business
in the school that's why people go to
Harvard because it's the connection
since you know people you know you don't
know you don't find some good people
here and there that's one thing I keep
with me because you know you you need
good people in your life and you know
that's what it's about because I
business as always go go up and down you
know that's always physical but you know
your life is it's constant you know who
are some of the actors that you've
worked with that it it became a
friendship that means a lot to you or
maybe it's a connection that you have
within that professionally you like I
think Christopher
yeah even even though I don't like him
the beginning tell us about that part
every time I met him in William Morris
office and you just keep talking
I did look at that guy's why why he keep
talking and I you know and he's so fast
you know mostly people like Brett Ratner
and like my manager Jackie the movie is
really good for you
I understand no and Krishna conduct I
don't know harder huh I just uh-huh
after he left
yeah haha after left patella ask my men
what the hell we talking about
I don't I don't even one word no I'm
going to come from his mouth and later
on using the movie and too young and too
young and come to the set there's so
many idea and he was a lay on the said I
was similar o'clock call I was at 6:30 I
already make up standing be I'm
filmmaker they are standing here then he
just come 11 our car
allez-y a lay I lay and step one day he
come to my open Oh Jackie can you come
later
yeah you make me look bad no this is my
job
no you have to write to come late tricks
did you did you no I said no I'm a
director I come I can come late and I'm
an actor actor on the set
that's my child but now Chris every day
on the set and do what just do the
really really good things now I I really
like him
yeah alright so now we just understand
you know and follow the rules or the now
is greatness mostly times if you're
talking where are you
I mean Hong Kong okay when you're coming
unless they're coming sooner we can tie
it together as okay okay mommy I'm so
glad to be here so honored to be here my
good friend my brother Phil another day
he's the biggest was the biggest movie
stars in the world and he has me well a
little time we made me one of all over
when we did one hour in a night I never
seen so much love from around the world
a jacket he spent already home from Asia
to Australia in Europe and he's leave he
helped me get known internationally and
it was such an honor to be able to
remember and decided with such comic
sinus timing how many kills and action
skill that was comedians three that was
my dream available that I do whatever I
want to do executives right there with
the right timing
wizzy and on we've been a Miss or a big
brother let's add the whole world and
because I want to be the friend also
have to be here today to celebrate this
big day the first our status
the tenements a friendly person consider
what
nc slip in here and I love it like a
brother and I'm happy for and other you
guys into and I'll have to meet you
thank you very much
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because David mayor's
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know what a crusader
had the biggest impact on you what was
your favorite rule from him what message
did he have that you can immediately
apply to your life or your business
leave it in the comments I'm going to
join in the discussion finally I want to
give a quick shout out to Carolyn Owens
Carolyn thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book your one word and
tweeting about it I hope you enjoy the
read thank you for your support so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
piss off man
this got me a new placement hey my
neighbor's man I got neighbors DeBarge
all the time you ever had a neighbor the
barrios I keep it so long you have to
borrowed back Roebuck apartment
no I've got dim room then aw man I got
rats and roaches like cooks and bloods
MouseMan be cruel but she was all the
time I come over work out the break-up
fight
mana be after my dough suck it on my
phone won't click over see my soul man
calling her from
my office Marty man they played it the
day I stepped on one I'm putting the
bathroom to get some tissue payback that
[ __ ] was gone I'm saving two weeks
later with some sick [ __ ] [ __ ] told me
you would soon legit to quit
[Applause]
[Music]
so when you going yo serious because
your problem already been an anger trip
man
whatever happened to pimp man what if
Michael Jackson was a pimp should be him
and see Toby ride around in the cat
election salon Tito so happy oh damn
is that my whole destiny on the curve
send me out money how much you get
I come Faro I got a son in the whole
field girl you're not here all day no
you guys know
[Applause]
you